i commit that i will in fact appoint a
i'll pick
a woman to be vice president there are a
number of women who are qualified to be
president tomorrow and
joe biden has delivered on tuesday the
presumptive democratic nominee
announced kamala harris as his vice
presidential candidate
making her the first black woman on a
major party presidential ticket
i have the great honor to announce that
i've picked at kamala harris
a fearless fighter for the little guy
and one of the country's finest public
servants
as my running mate biden tweeted in part
adding quote
back when kamala was attorney general
she worked closely with beau
i watched as they took on the big banks
lifted up working people
and protected women and kids from abuse
i was proud then and i'm proud now to
have her as my partner
in this campaign i want joe biden to win
and i will do in whatever capacity i'm
in everything in my power
to have him win shortly after biden
announced the big news
a number of hollywood celebs took to
social media with their reactions
whoopi goldberg was one of the first to
weigh in tweeting
senator kamala harris this is a great
moment
let's take care of her and make sure we
are supportive of her
because this is a no-nonsense race and
she is ready
go kamala whoopi's the view co-host joy
behar
also chimed in writing quote
congratulations to kamala harris
a frequent guest on the view she will be
an awesome partner to vp
biden what about the money going to
helping people with job training what
about helping
with the mental health issues that
communities are being plagued with for
which we're putting no resources
lakers star lebron james kept his
message simple
tweeting congrats and well-deserved
senator kamala harris
love to see and support it appreciate
you jb
and john legend tweeted in part quote
very much looking forward to voting for
the biden harris ticket
to begin the difficult work of
recovering from this nightmare
presidency
and building an even better future
meanwhile chrissy teigen
did not disappoint tweeting yes
excited to vote still amazed election
day isn't a national holiday
it needs to be celebrated with a
post-vote bar crawl
mindy kaling shared a two-part tweet
starting off
quote was there ever more of an exciting
day
for our entire country of course but
especially for my black and
indian sisters many of us who have gone
our entire lives thinking that someone
who looks like us
may never hold high office the actress
continued writing
now to see at senator kamala harris rise
to the top
like this it's thrilling i'm filled with
hope and excitement
[Music]
pink re-shared an article announcing the
news writing
real actual tears of joy over here in
the heart household and alongside
biden's tweet the singer adds quote
you both have my vote of course hillary
clinton
weighed in too tweeting i'm thrilled to
welcome at kamala harris to a historic
democratic ticket
she's already proven herself to be an
incredible public servant and leader
and i know she'll be a strong partner to
at joe biden
please join me in having her back and
getting her elected
and per usual barack obama gave us hope
tweeting in part this is a good day for
our country
now let's go win this thing election day
is tuesday november 3rd
you